[Music]
Christophe Govinda plays dr. Stockman
medical officer of the Newtown baths he
becomes an enemy of the people when he
insists on exposing the truth about an
environmental hazard in act for the
audience is called upon to intervene the
uncertainty hangs over every performance
will they cooperate or not monta maggots
Amazo and theft women sometimes we meet
someone who can tell us a little about
the people and customs first we didn't
have anyone here so in a way we're
running blind spring wasn't missing
fafsa
[Music]
and as far as the music's concerned
practice makes perfect
[Music]
missin type thing dr. Stockmann dr.
Stockman is the younger brother of the
mayor of a small town and discovers the
water in the municipal baths is
contaminated the clans ditches so
contaminated that it can damage people's
health bars really ought to be closed
immediately as well as bad egg dish
listen mr. first they're stolen his
brother the mayor wants to avoid closing
the baths at all costs because they're a
major source of revenue for the town's
Gibson wrote an enemy of the people over
130 years ago but it's still just as
relevant today let me shut my door upon
myself quite a lot but i also get quite
a bit from the person I'd like to be and
I know I'm not that person of the other
sawfish been
[Music]
the cast towards the ancient imperial
palace and soul Christophe Govinda sees
these encounters with foreign culture as
a necessary preparation and he takes the
time before every guest performance for
it they've already played in 28 cities
from Melbourne to Delhi Tehran Moscow
and Buenos Aires and every time the
audience has joined the discussion
everywhere but the Koreans are known for
their polite reserved an empty street is
a rare sight in Seoul it has a metro
population of 26 million people the
issues dividing a 19th century
provincial town in faraway Norway
reflect those of the 21st century's mega
cities economic mismanagement corruption
abused by politicians and the media as
well we'll all dis strike a chord in
Korea in part of neurons on target to be
honest after a day in the market I feel
a little nervous today this never was an
exact so I'm anxious to see if anything
comes from the audience at all hopefully
going to be too bad if it didn't I think
it'll be an educational experience for
all of us even if nothing happens
questionnaire far Werner investigar foam
and silence can also be incredibly
powerful and one in stock scientist I'm
not just concerned about whether
there'll be lots of discussion on a vice
been in SLE news I'm mainly interested
to see how they'll react to this
theatrical device if they'll accept it
and deal with it that's their bits ask
one of the most bizarre experiences was
definitely masculine all at once three
quarters of the audience came on stage
and brought the play to a halt and then
off TV no common domestic was Iggy
15 minutes to go before the curtain goes
up govinda's more nervous than usual the
theaters 1000 seats are sold out
[Music]
[Music]
hardly anyone in the audience speaks
German that won't make the improvisation
at the end any easier at this point
everyone turns against the idealistic
dr. Stockman enact for the house lights
come up Stockman calls a town meeting
and addresses the audience directly was
fiery rhetoric almost a left-wing
manifesto hru cooking dinner I think
many others okay I like to dance a week
of all whatever you spoke of a looming
apocalypse that people are destroying
the world do you really believe that we
the ones who fail to add to the problem
the majority can be mistaken
i partly agree with dr. Stockman there
are more important things than the
majority we have to find out the truth
we've learned that here whoever has
power can light of a nation we also have
an environmental scandal in Korea toxic
chemicals and ventilation systems killed
over 140 people and for years the
government tried to whitewash it and
cover up the cause the families have
been fighting for justice to this day
the audience didn't storm the stage but
they also did not show signs of reserve
the actors were surprised by parallels
between the play and the reality of the
environmental scandals that are now
rockin South Korea fabulous I wasn't
expecting this